how did this all come to be because this
was really a film written for Zack yeah
we'd been volunteering at a camp for
people with and without disabilities in
Venice Beach called Zeno Mountain Farms
and Zack we're making a short film with
Zack and he was making some really good
acting decisions he was playing a bad
guy so he said I want to come in I want
to take my glasses off set my drink down
and say my line cuz that's what the bad
guy would do and he was really good he
would stand out like that's a genius you
should do that and then we were having
having a conversation at dinner and he
said I want to get into features I want
to be a movie star and we had a real
conversation that there's not a lot of
roles written for people with Down
syndrome and he just said cool let's do
it together you and I ride it and I'll
star and we said let's gene that's
genius let's do that Zack how are you
feeling about this your very first film
experience how is peanut butter Falcon
for you I would say I would say I'm
great feel good and in in that dude look
this movie always have a turnout for all
for all the wonderful audience are here
right now so that given is that what do
you remember the first time that you met
Shia what was it like scientists like
having you know like how fun and siding
and talking some stuff and rapping
together and sorry I always been that
person right right it's hard you guys
wrapped together what are you all about
well when he gets rhythmic he gives very
articulate yeah so he he wants to talk
about like deeper subjects actually when
we get into rap it yeah the words come
easier
he's very rhythmic so we would sleeve
would wrap and we he'd he'd start
talking about how well it's too personal
for me to talk about actually just black
deep things yeah deep things and
Tyler and Michael let's talk about the
the rhythm of this film because there
definitely is a rhythm to it you
mentioned wanting to write something
specifically for Zach but I'm sure that
could have been a million things why
this particular story of these
particular people and this adventure and
wrestling we're really blessed to have
gotten to do it this large we thought we
were gonna make it for you know twenty
thousand dollars a sort of a small and a
really small indie so when we started
writing it yeah thank you guys by the
way really truly yeah so we started
writing it we kind of I'm from the Outer
Banks in North Carolina we just like
what do we have that we can sort of get
for free I grew up in a really kind of
unique blue-collar town I knew I had a
lot of friends with boats and I knew I
could get a lot of people to help me
there and so we wrote for that so we had
that element and we were trying to
tailor it for Zach so just sort of going
in and trying to what's the question
again I'm sorry but the story of these
three particular characters who all sort
of when they come together you see how
they fit together as a puzzle but you
know it could have been any number of
stories written for about Zach so why
this particular one I mean I'll jump in
here I think Tyler and I we wake up
every morning we have coffee and we talk
about what's going on the world what's
going on for us as individuals and I
think a lot of people feel broken and
alone and too when you write a story and
create a world it's a world that you get
to live in for a long time it took us a
year and a half to write it it took us
five years to get to this point from
that point and the world that we wanted
to live in was that world so we got to
manifest what our reality was and as I
think all of us are a little broken and
and to get to create an opportunity for
people to not feel so alone just felt
right so Albert and Chris let's talk
about the practicalities of making this
film when they first broached you
obviously a lovely story but probably
some things in there that you thought
mmm how is this all gonna work out can
you talk about what it took to make this
film yeah I mean the thing was the
script was great a friend sent us the
script he said he got to read this it
was great but along with the script came
a proof of concept that was incredible
maybe the best I've ever seen
Tyler and Mike worked on it with the
thiis who's another one of our producers
and what it did was they filmed like 10
seconds of many of the scenes in the
movie and you saw a real sense of
location and you saw that they really
knew what they were doing with camera
and you saw you know they built a little
boat and everything so it was a real
do-it-yourself kind of thing but most
importantly you saw that Zack could
carry a movie and Zack in that
proof-of-concept acted with Tyler and
you know Tyler was an actor before he
was a director and it was just so
impressive it really gave you the belief
and I think all of us that came to this
project the proof of concept had a huge
amount to do with our faith in what was
going to happen yeah it really did there
were some challenges with this project
that you know would would make a lot of
people run the other way we got
first-time filmmakers you've got a star
who this is his first feature film
we're shooting it's mainly outdoors in
the summer in the south a lot of water
work but in hot yeah oh very hot and
very storms every day and you know but
it was um there's a lot of challenges
but we when we saw this story and also
when we got to know Zach and saw what he
could do it became it became about
telling the story but also doing this
for Zach I mean a lot of this is we came
together so Zach could do this and and
it's a beautiful thing that we've made
here and of all the challenges that
Christopher just mentioned they didn't
talk about the fact that you get to
Russell we see you jumping off of really
high places I hear that you wanted to do
some of your own stunts can you tell you
about that yes I do like doing it
because I'm for me because of me I I
just feel like this year I decided to
prove to Tyler Tyler and Mike to know
how these two how to be are very good
after means something this to the two
I work on and end of me I just feel like
just go for our very hard challenge just
to take like very hard and and but this
one I have you know about about the arm
strength strength stay healthy and and
ditch keep on pushing it so hard because
because I don't - I cannot do it without
my having proved how I would be a real
good job to do it for them where I
matter what I do and I love it so much
and Shia what do you think you take away
from this is you act in other films I
know you're getting behind the camera
now - what do you take away from this
experience you're not never okay sorry I
had that wrong what do you take away
from this that you would like to use in
the other film projects in the future he
just forces you to listen in a different
way I hope we get to work with these
people again all around this is a very
special situation it's not like you can
replicate this on any other set this is
a very special special dance partner
that I don't think I'll ever have this
kind of relationship again there's no
lead-up to how how much he lets you in
I've never had a more intimate working
relationship with anybody I've ever
worked with
never known anybody is sincere I've
never been carried like this so I don't
think I'll ever get this again there's
no no way I don't even have hopes to
ever see something like this again I'm
just happy it happened this time yeah
and you're right when you said that you
know he did make me better he is my
whole performance
I mean his I'm stealing his look and I'm
I'm falling into his eyes and that's
really what you just saw yeah Zak some
people who see this film might never
have met someone with Down syndrome
before what do you hope the people who
see peanut butter Falcon will understand
about who you are in people with Down
syndrome
blah people always in a big scene just
like me about everything that I'm about
like um I'll say going through and going
on very hard and just to them I'm just -
I'm home - um struggle to being
disturbing in school and sometimes most
most most teachers didn't teach very
well to this to this to them teach the
student how to be a very good after
dozens of people like me I'll say
everybody could try their best what they
can do is to just to keep on just keep
on them study and plays and an hour till
before before you can read from the top
then they can be successful to be a
pretty good actor to be part of this
movie myself I hate doing happy working
so hard for like all of my life just to
be in this big movie I not going I'm not
want you back down and I'm not going to
give up keep on trying and do a really
hard work to prove though teacher will
understand how those children can be a
real good actor is all about is how iris
that's how I always became of the peanut
butter Falcon I cannot wait to see what
you do next sack and I think there's a
lot of people here who feel the same way
thank you so much